- But this is the part of the
show where we usually talk
about something I'm obsessed with
but I thought since
we're in your home, what,
since you've been and your
new home, the White House
it's such a weird thing to say.
What are you obsessed with?
- You know, I think
I've been obsessed with
getting our dogs settled
because we have a old dog
and we have a very young dog.
So just, you know, they
have to take the elevator.
They're not used to that.
They have to go out on the,
the south lawn with lots
of people watching them.
- And that's just rude
while you're trying to
do your business, yeah.
That's unfortunate.
- I turn my head.
- Yeah, everyone's taking pictures.
- Yeah, so you know, it's,
that's what I've been obsessed with,
just getting everybody settled
and calm and you know.
- Dogs help, I think, I find that
I've never lived, like been alive
without a dog in my
household, but where do they,
do they have like a
favorite spot like to go?
- Well, they don't have a favorite spot.
They'd like to be
wherever we are, you know?
And they're always, even
if my door is closed,
they're sitting right outside the door.
Like, let me in, let me in.
- Oh, that's my dog Henry.